2026년 5월 8일 금요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
견주한 고용지표와 반도체주 강세가 맞물리며 위험자산 선호 심리가 다시 살아났습니다.
여기에 미국과 이란이 전쟁 종식을 위해 중재국들과 양해각서 작성을 추진하고 있다는 소식도 투자 심리에 우호적으로 작용했습니다.
월스트리트 저널은 미국과 이란이 중재국들과 함께 전쟁 종식을 목표로 한 달간 이어질 협상의 틀을 담은 양해각서를 마련 중이라고 보도했습니다.
다만 장중 호르무주의협 인근에서 다시 한번 군사적 충돌이 발생하기도 했습니다.
그럼에도 시장은 이러한 지정학적 잡음보다 견주한 경제 펀더멘털에 더 무게를 두는 모습이었습니다.
특히 기업들의 긍정적인 실적이 시장 분위기를 든든하게 뒷받침했습니다.
지금까지 1부였습니다.
3분기 실제 발표한 S&P500 기업 440곳 중 83%가 애널리스트들의 전망치를 상해하며 장기 평균인 67%를 크게 웃돌았습니다.
S&P500 지수는 0.84% 상승 마감하며 사상 최고치를 다시 한번 경신했습니다.
개별 종목의 흐름을 살펴보면 마이크론이 15% 급등하고 샌디스크가 16% 폭등하는 등 반도체주의 강세가 곧 보였습니다.
인텔토원 애플의 일부 기계 탑재는
인텔토원의 탑재대칩을 제조하는 예비 계약을 체결했다는 보도에 힘입어 14% 급등했습니다.
한편 투자자들은 전쟁의 파급 효과를 가늠하기 위해 경제 지표에도 주목했습니다.
4월 비누업 부분 고용은 11만 5천명 증가해 시장 예상치인 5만 5천명 훌쩍 뛰어넘었으며 약 1년 만에 처음으로 두 달 연속 증가세를 기록했습니다.
이처럼 견주한 고용 지표는 최근 몇 주 사이 소비자 심리가 사상 최저치로 떨어졌다는
부정적인 데이터를 압도했습니다.
노슬라이트의 크리스 자카 랠리는
경제는 비관론자들이 말해온 것보다 훨씬 더 양호하다.
여러 역풍이 존재함에도 불구하고 노동시장은 굳건하다.
네이션와이드의 마크 헷깃은
약세론자들은 랠리가 반도체 등 특정 영역에만 집중되어 있다는 점을 계속 지적하고 있다.
하지만 긍정적인 주가 흐름과 실적 전망 상향이라는 모멘텀이 시장 상승을 이끄는 핵심 동력이 되고 있다.
글로벌트 인베스먼트의 키스 브케노는
시장은 우리가 직면한 위험을 충분히 반영하지 않은 밸레이션에서 거래되고 있다.
지금은 AI 관련 지출과 그 파급효과 그리고 실적이 맞물려 경제를 떠받치고 있는 상황으로
이러한 지출과 낙관론이 없었다면 경제는 상당히 부진했을 것이다. 라고 전하였습니다.